the Trump administration calls a meeting
a success in its own right Norah
O'Donnell is leading our coverage from
Helsinki Finland Nora good morning to
you again
hey good morning to you that's right a
little drama to start off today's summit
because I got off to a late start in
part because President Putin arrived
about an hour behind schedule kept Trump
waiting the two leaders are now meeting
behind closed doors with just
translators now that is unprecedented to
have a u.s. president and a Russian
president meet alone like that for that
period of time and while the
expectations from the president are low
the world's are extremely high US
ambassador to Russia Jon Huntsman said
people should not expect any major
breakthroughs members of Congress on
both sides of the aisle say they hope
the president will bring up Russia's
meddling in the 2006 presidential
election you hear other current
diplomats and intelligence officials say
not only what Russia has done in the
past what they are doing right this day
in terms of attacking American democracy
this also comes just days of that after
that indictment of 12 Russian agents
they're facing a number of election
related charges including conspiracy to
commit computer crimes and identity
theft and then it should not go and
notice what the Director of National
Intelligence said just before the summit
started he said the threat of a
cyberattack still isn't over saying US
infrastructure is literally under attack
major Garrett is also here in Helsinki
he's been reporting on what the
administration hopes to achieve and use
some US officials who are worried about
potential concessions the president may
make in that private meeting major
well good morning nor as you said it is
unprecedented for an American president
to have this much time alone with
Russian President Vladimir Putin but it
is not unprecedented for president
Trump's approach to diplomacy remember
at mar-a-lago early in his presidency he
met one-on-one with GG ping the Chinese
president he prefers one-on-one
interaction because he has this really
bottomless sense of self-confidence
about taking the measure of a world
leader in that space whether it's just
the two of them and negotiating on his
behalf
on behalf the United States in his way
and his way only without any other
interference or any other minders that
creates an opportunity but it also
create risks in Brussels at the NATO
summit I encountered many NATO ministers
who were somewhat anxious about the
prospect of Russian President Vladimir
Putin talking president Trump into may
be an official or unofficial semi
recognition of Russia's annexation of
Crimea
maybe cancelling NATO joint military
exercises in the Baltics doing things
that from a NATO perspective would
weaken the Alliance and strengthen
Russia none of that has happened but the
anxiety about that and what could occur
in this face-to-face one-on-one meeting
is all too real Nora major thank you and
we don't know what may come out of that
private meeting or whether we'll even
get a clear read from either of those
presidents about just exactly what they
discussed there will be a working lunch
as major has talked about where there
will be an expanded group of advisers on
both teams to talk about issues and then
a press conference from both President
Trump and President Putin where White
House advisers assured me again just
this morning that they will take
questions from the press and that hasn't
happened in more than a decade so it
will be extraordinary to see those two
leaders on the stage taking questions so
for more on what to expect from the
summit let's go back to John in New York
John all right Nora thanks so much